once you recognize emptiness then that's
it like you once you lose the center of
experience it never comes back again
ever
so once that's done there's no more to
be done in terms of the passionate for
me so what I do now is even after the
sentence is up there's there can still
be some really deep conditionings that
are left in like you know the very deep
part of your body and then that usually
takes like you know seven to ten years
to dissolve to complete dissolve some
teachers say it doesn't completely
dissolve you you go through for the rest
of your life you're going to be
integrating this inside because this
life just goes on because life is
conditionings right so what I do now is
just I just sit there and do nothing and
then just let awareness sort of clean up
the whatever remainder of the
solidarities uh the remainder of the
condition is that that's that are still
there so that's the integration part
like they like to say you first wake up
and then clean up and grow up
so the cleaning up part is pretty much
the integration part yeah so another
really common technique that people use
is uh kind of like a contemplation path
it's called self-inquiry so self-inquiry
is also called The Natty Natty method so
19990 means not this not this is not
that not bad so anything that arises in
your direct experience you just label it
in a visceral way uh you kind of have to
feel it out you know not just
intellectually now this is not me this
is not self right 1990 not this not that
so it's very easy in the beginning when
you just perceive a cup and you're like
oh this is not me it's easy right but
then uh you start to know cessations too
uh the sound oh sound is rising not this
uh the visual field is rising not that
um when you get to the mind it gets a
little tricky can you perceive thought
can you look at the thought of yourself
if you can look at it if you can
perceive it or experience it it's not
this not that
right so it's just kind of putting away
the layers of the audience right and
then when it goes down to the very deep
end of it
you start to perceive even the witness
okay you witness the witness
if you can witness the witness the
witness is also not South
can you perceive perception itself
perception is also not self can you be
aware of awareness can you be conscious
of consciousness
can you perceive even God Consciousness
if so
if you have an experience of God
Consciousness then it's still something
that's a rising experience then you
simply objectify that as well say oh
that's not me that's self
so you kind of objectify everything your
direct experience until the subject
vanishes
you turn everything into an object
right so once you turn everything your
direct experience including uh this
whole field of Consciousness into an
object then where's the subject
it disappeared into it
so one way to look at is that there's
only the object there's only the world
and there's no self
and another way to look at it is that
there's only the subject always self
There's No Object so that's another way
to merge the true self in the no self
School
right you know deleted Duality between
subject and object okay so I'm sure
westerners get wrong plenty about
imagination and how this may lead to
quote unquote manifestation most people
at least in the west believing that it's
a fantasy of a Kind the way I look him
at a station is
just let the universe or just let your
experience or or fold without a doer
so if you just let nature unfold without
a doer pretty much every single moment
is manifestation that's how I look at
manifestation manifestation to me is not
communicating with higher power it's not
visualizing some things that you want
and then getting it because when you
realize emptiness you don't want
anything anymore because everything is
full
so there's nothing that I want in terms
of like manifestation but then every
moment is manifestation
so like the way I experience reality is
like it's kind of like just the universe
giving birth to itself moment to moment
to moment that's the ultimate
manifestation
yeah that's high like a motive station
because I I don't know how to answer
that question because I don't really
manifest things because I don't need I
don't feel like I need to like there's
nothing that I want to benefit it seems
like everything that is happening
whether imperfection or Perfection is
just the way it is like in my direct
experience there's no such thing as
imperfection like even the quote-unquote
imperfection is perceived to be perfect
right even that's going back to how like
formal and emptiness are identical right
like even solidity is perceived to be
air
so so like again going back to the the
process of like dissolving yourself from
like solid object to to liquid to smoke
to air then what is a like what is a
hologram the Hologram is pretty much an
emptiness in form combined right you see
an object but then it's actually
holographic
and it's all our emotions the way I
experience emotions and perceptions and
uh objects and entities are all
holographic even when I perceive a rock
it feels like I can just penetrate
through it it feels like I'm just
perceiving something that doesn't have
any inherent existence that it's just
just an image
so for me there's no difference between
imagination and reality
yeah it's just particles and Sensations
yeah like the fundamental structure of
the image in the mind is not different
than the fundamental structure a texture
of the image conical outside the mind
because there's no difference between
inside and outside
that
okay so the rebuttal is that the real
world has more solidity
yeah
uh oh yes that's just a level and a
degree of solidity but it's made out of
the same stuff like dreams are a less
solidified version of cultural reality
so when you are walking around the in
the waking World things are more solid
when you go to sleep things are more
liquidy
so the reason why when you take a
psychedelics things start to breathe and
start to morph and colors start to
change is because at that moment when
you take the Psychedelic your brain or
your mind is becoming more malleable
you're dissolving the mind that's why
people get glimpses of their true nature
on psychedelics because when you take a
psychologic drugs it dissolves your
lenses of perception and you dissolved
the solidity in your experience very
quickly but then if you dissolve them
very quickly they also come back and
contract back into form very quickly
but through meditation you go through
years to the years of this rewarding the
brain into like locking that Insider
realization into a permanent state
tell us about any states of bliss or
negative entities that you've
encountered
okay so I've experienced a lot of crazy
like on my journey um
I would say when I was going through the
unfoldments I was experiencing mystical
experiences that are just as powerful if
not more powerful than like my DMT trip
like I remember the the shift into
non-duality like my first thought was
this is like as powerful as my favorite
meal DMT trip but now I see my now is my
direct perception now it's my direct
experience but now it's completely
ordinary to me now so the only reason
why you think your 5mm experience which
is you know non-duality or boundless
space uh just having a glimpse of your
true nature is because it's only insane
or it's only a profound experience again
relative to the ego mind
so any kind of spiritual experiences or
mystical states that you have is the
byproduct and the side effect of the
dissolution of your conditioning and
that's where a lot of people in the
spiritual Circle get around is that they
think that Mr experiences are the thing
that they're supposed to uh be looking
for basically expenses are really nice
you know I've had experiences of like
going to other dimensions
um entities
past lives again just the experiences
that are just as powerful as like
psychedelic trips but then now they're
all transcended in a sense because there
is not much conditional that in this
body mind so
experiences of most of it and and
musical experiences you know even
entities visiting me and things like
that they're just a byproduct of my
subconscious mind getting burned off
One Step dream is unfolded
there's not going to be much of those
experiences anymore what you get is just
the business
because the the entities and other
dimensions and physical experiences
still poses uh form it's just the
content that are rising in this vast
context of the infinite consciousness